now you are an NBA champion Nicola how
does that feel it's good it's good the
job is down we can go home now
congratulations set after the Lakers
when you said you were surprised that
you didn't feel more so I'm curious what
you are feeling right now and if you're
looking forward to a parade coming up in
Denver
men's parade
Wednesday Thursday
no
I need to go home okay
uh
parade coming up here on Thursday yes
how soon till you're back inside for the
Sundays I have my horse racing horse
racing I was gonna
maybe I don't know how we're going to
arrive Thursday at 8 Friday maybe would
you make it I don't know
maybe maybe you can have enough time to
squeeze it in I'm gonna ask Josh to give
me a give me a give me a plane oh I
think I think you I think he'll
definitely let you get the team playing
I think you deserve that you deserve a
little more than that I did it on TV I'm
gonna finish my uh I put him under the
pressure yes I did I don't feel bad at
all help us win the championship
Nicola the dinner you guys had at Jeff
Green's house was very well documented
to what extent is tonight's Victory a
psychological Victory and to what extent
is that a result of great team building
like that dinner
he has a nice house
yes he has a nice house and when you
look at the future what is this capable
of propelling you guys because I think
you have the starting five lockdown for
maybe the next couple years
I didn't know that that's great uh but
to be honest I don't think about the
next year I'm gonna ask the coach to
give him a couple weeks a couple weeks
more off uh so I can I can be ready for
the season uh
that's supposed to be a joke and you
didn't laugh
good job guys you are the first person
in NBA history to have a 30 20 10
NBA Finals game what does that mean to
you I mean to be honest not not much uh
I figured you were gonna say that you're
the fourth player in NBA finals history
to record the line that you had today
joining LeBron uh KD and Tim Duncan uh
what do you think about when you hear
that
it's not a bigger than 23 12 and 4.
whatever the 23 10 and 4.
oh
I mean I don't know nice it's a good uh
I mean I really don't don't know what to
say
you have a stats
your country can make history in the
next few days we acknowledge yokovic
winning his 23rd Grand Slam and you with
your first NBA championship what does it
mean for Serbia
yes of course actually he texted me for
real
yes he texted me yes yes he texted me
for real he didn't lie Novak just won
the French Open you just won the finals
MVP and the championship is this the
greatest era of Serbian athletes
we're going to be
ah congratulations I'm gonna see it a
huge testing you know
I don't know I mean oh
[Music]
I'm gonna turn off the phone bro
please like who
am I after because we really haven't
seen a big in the game quite like you I
think it's Shaq
thanks a lot thank you brother
I'm not a joke I appreciate that there
is a bunch of things that uh
that I like that I like to do I mean
probably that's no that's a normal thing
you know nobody likes his uh his job or
maybe they do they're lying it's
Champions Trophy on behalf of the Denver
Nuggets head coach Michael Malone
[Applause]
do you ever give us today or during the
playoff do you ever speak to the team
like a locker room speech
let me know I mean
[Music]
um I just wanted to make fun at least a
little bit you know
and I hope it's hoping he's gonna pay my
fine but uh
Nicola Mike Michael Malone said that you
were coaching them up in the fourth
quarter kind of it gave you credit for
saying let's go to the two-man game what
what is coach jokic like
I don't know I don't want to be a coach
and I think that there's the water
travel on the planet for sure
how have you grown and what have you
learned from being a dad and have you
noticed any of those skills translating
to being a better basketball player
nah and um that cannot help you tonight
most triple doubles by a center congrats
on that one too thank you yeah thank you
there you go very Shack in that is the
shack in that list no no because I never
passed
[Laughter]
is it possible to ask in Serbian
do you ask me um yeah go ahead
I know
it's really nice
now it's my turn good job you want to I
guess I'm going y'all
give a round of applause
two and a half minutes of this game 10
in the first quarter after just
just in all of game four and you were
wondering if maybe this oh they weren't
playing at a high efficiency level early
on front right
you're drunk
Nicola
uh uh you know that I I told that uh I
don't want to stay on Parade but I
[__] want to stay on period
surprise
well this is this is amazing